تعملوا الاكاديميه الوطنيه البحريه على
تدريب وتاهيل الكوادر السعوديه واكسابهم
المهارات المرتبطه باصلاح وبناء السفن
والملاحه والهندسه البحريه وكذلك تشغيل
الموانئ والخدمات البحريه الاخرى وهي
الاولى من نوعها في مجال التدريب البحري
في السعوديه علي الاغبيوتر
برامج تعليميه ودورات قصيره في اكثر من
300 تخصص في المجال البحري تقدمها
الاكاديميه الوطنيه البحريه اول اكاديميه
بحريه معتمده في السعوديه والاولى من
نوعها في مجال التدريب البحريه
برامج مختلفه في القطاع البحري منها تشغيل
السفن بشكل عام اا كل ما يتعلق بتشخيص في
الموجود كابتن بحرين مهندس بحري مهندس
كهربائي والكترونيات همم بحار ميكانيكي
طاقم بشكل عام كما نوفر برامج
اجهزه محاكاه بها 65 نظامه محاكاه مختلفه
وفقه متطلبات المعايير البحريه الدوليه
للتدريب على الملاحه والهندسه البحريه
وانظمه التحميل والتنزيل المتعلقه
بالمواني والسفن
يوجد عدد كبير من المحاكيات في الاكاديميه
هذه المحاكيات تعتبر الافضل على مستوى
العالم همم تقريبا 65 محاكي همم الى الان
فساعدنا لتوفير التدريب الافضل طلبتنا
بحيث يكونوا على نفس المستوى العالمي
المطلوب لتدريب البحري بشكل عام تضم
الاكاذبيه نحو 263 متدربا في تسعه مجالات
ابرزها الكابتن والمهندس البحري ومهندس
الكهربائي والالكترونيات في حين خرجت
الاكاديميه حتى الان نحو 32 خريجان في
صيانه وتشغيل السفن البحريه تخص الكابتن
بحري همم المرحله هذه دورات الامن
والسلامه من دورات القياده همم اكاديميه
وفرضتنا يعني اجهزه محاكاه تعيشنا جو
البحر
والحمد لله قريب ان شاء الله وزملائي راح
نتخرج اكاديميه البرامج تعليميه متعدده
بدايه من الفصول الدراسيه بعد كذا بنصال
الغرف المحاكاه وتنتهي بالورش الداخليه
داخل الاكاديميه البرامج المتعدده جدا من
ناحيه ورش كبيناء سفن او عمليات اخرى من
ناحيه المحاكاه تدريب بقياده السفن او
عمليات التحميل والتنزيل داخل السفينه
تقوم الاكاديميه على شراكه استراتيجيه بين
ارامكو السعوديه والمؤسسه العامه للتدريب
التقني والمهني بدعم من صندوق تنميه
الموارد البشريه وعدد من شركات القطاع
البحري واعتماد من مواني وهيئه النقل
وكلياتي التميز
من الجبيل العالي النقبي العربيه